so with the second part I don't think
there will be a third part but let's
focus on the second one so I already
show you that the goal of formal method
is a building application that are
correct and now in this part I don't
know the number but I will focus on a
formal verification which is a we can
think about it as a kind of sub branch
of formal methods that aim at approving
application correct so before it was
about a building application that are
correct with respect to differential
privacy now we take something that
people can design in their own way and
we try to prove them different
differentially private yes so formal
verification is quite old it started
more or less when it started and I like
usually presented through the world of
terrain who already thought a bit about
this problem and it was asking himself
how can one check a routine in the sense
of making sure that it is right and the
ants were was already there in order
that the man who checks ok his mistake
was this one not only a man but a man in
the machine who checks may not have too
difficult that as the programmer should
make a number of definite assertion
which can be checking the Mid Valley and
from which the correctness of the old
program and directly follow and this is
what I will do in this hour I will take
some example and do exactly this I go
step by step through assertions and show
you how we can prove a program
differentially private if I get there
other pictures okay I could have taken a
real picture right so mainly they the
overall picture is disease we provide
the program with some annotation and the
verification tool try to check if this
is a valid program so that satisfy the
property we want in particular for us it
will be differential privacy an
important aspect of modern verification
is that we use a lot of tools which help
us doing this in a is automated as
possible
so let's look back at our example that
we started with this one so we already
saw that these fail to meet the
specification it was the example about
addition now let's try to fix the
program first I just replace 0 with
Tech's so now I'm pretty confident that
this program computer Edition and so it
meets the specification now how can we
prove that it meet the specification if
you have already seen these and maybe is
not anything really new but a standard
way to do this is to try to push through
assertion the this precondition forward
and try to derive at the post condition
from it going through the problem
another approach would be to pull the
post condition backward so trying to see
if this is indeed the follow from that
ok now this is a kind of game I will
choose the direction of going forward
because I think is a little more easy to
present on paper although automated
technique try to go more backward but I
will try to use the forward direction
and I call it a game because I will
introduce some role of
the game which tell us how to step from
a platform that were posed for mana by
looking at each of these so every time I
later I will do several step at the same
time but every time I pass through one
of this line I will apply a rule of the
game now I will use only rule that are
correct that they are sound and I will
avoid doing this year but they are
proved correct again with respect to
some semantic model as I was saying
before I will not do it here but there
is a the rule that I when I introduce a
new rule I need to do this proof I did
it before I will not do it here but this
is important is human proof sir is there
like another turtle under this like by
you or by like another machine you can
do either you can usually we do it on
paper we do a combination so you can
prove it with another machine so yeah
they are still now mainly they if we
think about trust the trust has been
moved to this the soundness of desire
Allah so these are the trusted
components so let's try to prove
corrected in this program now I
reformulate a bit what I call the
precondition I just introduced to and
the postcondition introduced to variable
v NW which make it a little easier but
they if you do a little of rewriting the
precondition is the same and I will
start by pushing this condition so it's
exactly the same condition I just remove
the precondition name through the
function and we are just putting it in
the function so I assume that this is a
simpler rule
I can apply I just push it now the
question is how shall I move next so
what is the first rule that I introduce
here we have an assignment that say R is
equal to X so what shall I do now now
what we can do is using this rule let's
say that if we have an assignment like
this where to X we assign e then we can
derive a starting from a formula where
arbre occurrence of X's are replaced by
E the formula itself let me show you
some example that maybe it clarifies
what I mean so for instance I can I can
prove from a is equal to Y I can push it
forward and say that X is equal to Y
because I exaggerate the property of a
another example I can from X plus 1
greater than 0 I can say if I do X equal
to X plus 1 that X is greater than 0
because again I inherit the property of
X plus 1
another kind of example is from 3 equal
to 3 applying the fact that X is equal
to 3 I can derive notice how I
formulated so the formula lets this is
the only place where I go a little
backwards so the formula is the one on
the bottom and they replace in the top
so I replace all the occurrences for
instance here yeah I replace X with free
so should the precondition I can also
that is good but this is good as well
yeah exactly that's where a bit of
creativity is needed so that's where you
can choose so you see here I replace
again these X with X plus 1 replace this
X with ay so going down I have some
choice
okay so if I apply this ruler here
mainly what I get is that doing a semi
transformational I have R equal to B I
can apply this rule again and I also get
that n is equal to W and here is where I
used this additional variable now let me
change another rule that I can do that I
didn't write up explicitly is that I
have a bit of game in now I can change
this formula if I preserve the validity
of the formula so in particular ER I
rewrite R equal to V plus W minus n so
why I'm allowed to do that because N and
W are equal so I'm adding and removing
the same element
okay
all right so why do I need this at an 11
is because now I'm going into a while
where I need some form of invariant to
be preserved and this is the reason why
I do this and we will see in a moment
when I when I give the rule for a while
actually let me remove I change it a
little more because I now say it
something like this R plus 1 is equal to
V plus W and minus 1 again I'm adding
plus 1 on both sides so their qualities
preserve and I forget a bit the rest
that who make a bit simpler now I try to
propagate it through the while and I
keep applying the rule way so before and
that this get transform in particular
notice that now I replace this R plus 1
with R and then I replace the N minus 1
with end
now if you notice here I have the same
rule that I the same constraint I had
before entering the wine I don't know if
I emphasize this enough so let's go back
here so I add the dis constraint R equal
to B plus W minus and so what I what I
show with this step is that this can be
recreated after going through the wine
now these bring us to the wire order
which is this one if we can find the
formula that and if we can find the
formula for which we can do this so we
take can take the formula and the
condition of the wine and prove the same
formula after the body then that I can
prove that this formula is also true for
the wine it absolves for the while and
in particular if we load with the
negation of the condition after the wine
yes does that show that the condition is
ever violated like there's a termination
issue and well yeah there is a some
termination issue that I'm a completely
living under the carpet here Y was
negative the problem of Y being negative
was not true exactly
correctness of formulas yeah yeah yeah
exactly so usually there is we
distinguish between total correctness
and partial correctness whether you also
prove termination or you assume
termination there are technique to deal
with all of these I just try to leave
them under the carpet to avoid the
discussion but I'm happy to discuss more
interesting yeah but there is that issue
so in general we call this kind of
formula invariant because is an
invariant through the loop and it allow
us to prove that the formula still owns
after the loop with the negation of the
condition so in particular if I do this
I use this rule and the same formula
will apply here sorry but also with the
negation of the condition so the formula
is this and I applied the negation of
the condition which say that mainly n is
equal to zero and so this will become
just the apply equal V plus W and this
is actually what we need for matching
the post condition okay so this is a an
eye-level introduction to how
verification work and now I did it
manually but let's try to do it with the
tool I just want to give you a feeling
of how far we can go
that wise
all right
nice night this design very bad alright
so then I want to say also
in the meantime that is connecting I
wanted also to correct something I said
before pink actually already in the
first version that contain at the
exponential mechanism I say the
something wrong before so is available
this year and yeah it was there all
right so these I don't know if you can
see it that is something let me correct
this is exactly how we did it before so
this is exactly the example we were
looking at where requires is the
precondition and ensure is the post
condition and we also provide an
invariant to the program now if I try
this is a tool that people at Microsoft
Research design for this kind of
verification now if I try to execute the
original problem the original program we
have some error we cannot prove it
correct and we know that is not correct
because it doesn't compute the addition
because of this zero so if now I fix it
to X
the verification goes through and assay
is verified okay so this is to give you
a bit of a flavor of how much of this is
automated in particular you see what we
need to provide is this part and this
part now there is a lot of research in
to try to remove this part at all so
inferring invariant is a very active
research topic and I think also this
tool does some inference of invariant so
ideally we would like really to provide
just preconditions and postconditions
and all the rest done be done
automatically okay
all right but finding the right is
probably the hardest part yeah finding
the invariant is they are this part and
people are considering many different
technique to do that from constraint
solving quite advanced constraint
solving to using machine learning
technique but I think especially in the
constraint solving they have very
sophisticated technique to find the
invariant even assuming that the
precondition and post condition are
correct they they find the invariant yes
in if you're verifying more complicated
programs like how easy is it to specify
things like the post condition like if I
wanted to like your example the post
condition is something that's basically
like a first order operation exactly so
let's look at one more complex post
condition like sorriness like I mean is
this the Trivium no I'm saying like this
sounds very long time saying okay you
know where between like i6y and like
this program is differentially private
does it start to become kind of
challenging yeah so I think let's take
assorted Anessa which is something that
people have looked a lot into so
specifying the post condition is quite
easy because you need to specify a price
of course there is a a madam a some kind
of mathematical way of specifying
actually here in like in this tool you
can use the same language to specify
both the program and post condition and
you can specify a predicate that say
this list is sorted which doesn't have
to do at all with the algorithm and then
usually is really just about finding the
right invariant let's see
so in writing such a predicate you're
allowed to use coil you are allowed to
use quantifier yeah I will come back to
this a bit later when I will talk about
solving so let's talk about differential
privacy and let me take a simple example
this is lightly different from the one I
took before this is just compute I try
to take the simplest one just computing
CDF and then add in Laplace to him this
CDF of one value so just how many
element of the data set are less than C
so now the question is water
precondition impose condition here so
ideally by the definition we know that
we would like something like this for
every two databases differing in one
individual the precondition and then the
result are epsilon this Delta
indistinguishable okay so yeah this is
what ideally we would like now there are
two problem here so the first problem
has to do with the precondition with
actually both of them is that this
quantification of two databases I
already mentioned this before so who are
these two databases if you look at the
verification we did before we were
working with the input but here we are
talking about two input okay
the second one is this one how we
formulate the result our epsilon Delta
indistinguishable
so to solve the first approach there is
a classic technique in verification
which is consider relational reasoning
where we consider instead of one program
we consider two programs in particular
but now we can talk about the input of
one and the input of the other here I
took the same program because we are
interested in verifying differential
privacy which usually talk about one
program but in general and for
verification is convenient where the two
programs although I will use only one
program in my presentation now
the problem is the post condition so now
we can we can express the precondition
the problem is the post condition
because this is what epsilon-delta in
this thing we shall be little min now
why this is a problem the problem is as
to do with the old verification
infrastructure so I said that we want to
rely as much as possible on automated
and semi-automated tool as you saw in
the simple demo I gave that we have
behind the tool that salt constraint now
do we have some good decision or semi
decision procedure for epsilon
indistinguishability and is it the way
to go so just if you are not too
familiar with solver or maybe you are
more familiar than me with some kind of
solver let me try to give you an idea of
how we think about solver in programming
languages so I'm sure you all know how
to solve a linear set of constraints I
think is something that most of you have
seen before and usually we can consider
them as kind of easy because they are a
simple constrain
this doesn't mean that is always good
having many of them we know that there
are there is complexity issue but here
I'm not considering complexity issues
but I'm trying to motivate the kind of
salt that we use so these are in my view
quite simple then we have nonlinear set
of constraint which start to be more
complex and then we have first order
formulas with twenty fires and these are
all also quite complex depending if you
are over the really if you are over the
integrator if you are over mix in the
Galleria and then finally there is what
we use which are a satisfy satisfy
ability model OTS SMT solvers which put
together different theories using first
order logic okay so in this kind of
setting we can specify predicates we can
have numeric for instance a nonlinear
arithmetic and we can abandon arithmetic
we can have a bunch of different areas
theories put together ok this is a the
kind of usual target of our verification
why this is the usual kind of target
because we can do what John was asking
here we can write a predicate that say
this list is sorted by using logic
formulas and then we can try to verify
them
so we base our verification a lot of
their deeds now why this is good for us
so I think the one that is the main
point is this one which often is not
what people that come from the theory
background think about so usually you
are for the theory background people are
more used to try to reduce a problem to
another in a specific way that you can
solve and maybe the constraint using a
linear arithmetic and you are done for
us instead we are trying to have a kind
of a very general way to encode the
constraint because we want to consider
all the possible programs and we want to
consider very complex pre and post
condition so we don't want to reduce to
linear constraint we want to add as much
as possible I relied to the solver the
effort of trying to verify them so the
other reason is a sanity solver are good
at handling combination of inductive
theories and numeric theories for
instance if you want to work with arrays
you have a theory of array that you can
use directly in the solder and also in
theory they could support counting
theories like the one that we need the
to reason about probabilities the
problem actually they can support theory
like counting theories but the problem
is is unclear how to make them scale in
practice
all right any question on this
then I go back to our goal so because we
use this has 70 solver and as I said
they could reason about probabilities
Baron is not clear how to make them
efficient and skill to big imagine
probability distribution with a very big
support then we want to avoid as much as
possible reasoning about probabilities
for this reason we my collaborator and I
but also people before I look at how to
verify this relation and properties and
probabilistic relational property and a
technique that emergen is of is the
following we call it reasoning with
approximate probabilistic coupling and I
will explain later why is this but is
the idea of just use some some logical
constraint as a post condition and
require also some additional property in
the case of differential privacy we want
to ask that we pay them most Epsilon so
this seems maybe like natural because
it's what we did also for pink but in
some sense is a non-trivial change
because we need to guarantee that this
is a good sound way of characterizing
differential privacy and I will talk a
bit more about this later
okay since I to simplify I will just
consider one program but I will use a
design this is one in two to talk about
the two possible run the database one in
database two and so on okay so how do we
verify our example
so our precondition now is that b1 and
b2 differing in one individual data just
as a shortened I will write it in this
way so I will write b1 squiggle 1 b2
okay
now I add slides for doing this example
completely button then I realize I'm
running out of time so let's say that by
some standard reasoning like the one I
showed you before in the example of odd
we can do the non that non probabilistic
part okay in particular in this example
what will happen is that the adjacency
relation we have on the data set will be
propagated on the counting we are
counting with CDF and so it will be just
that propagated this adjacency relation
to the county so now the interesting
part is what we do with Laplace because
now we have a probabilities so what can
we say about Laplace and here is where
we use this first rule let's say that if
I have two inputs which are adjacent and
I add Laplace with Absalom parameter
epsilon then I can say that they output
are equal by paying epsilon you really
mean like whatever epsilon like this is
not to be taken as the like variance
while sits just yet are you agree but
usually we use Laplace as a Laplace of
one over okay yes
that's yes it depends on how you
implement the Laplace presentation okay
but I agree all right so now remember I
said before when we introduce Rolo we
need to prove them sound in the
semantics now is in the semantics that
we use this approximate coupling I
mentioned before and I will come back to
that but for there will mainly is this
rule that we get okay you just say
mainly by paying epsilon we cannot
distinguish anymore the output now by
applying this rule we get that the
output cannot be distinguished and so we
are done we prove this differentially
private because that was our goal so our
goal just to make sure going back here
it was exactly to prove this equivalence
and paying at most Epsilon and we did
this
okay
now
I will skip a bit on how this account
for multiple queries and I can do
composition and I can sum the epsilon
and so on because it's a in spirit a
similar to what we saw so far with being
a rabbit and puds
and I will try to focus on something a
bit different
also because last time I showed that
part a Thomas told me oh but this is on
tribulus oh I want to show something
that is non-trivial it was a some years
ago and actually this comment motivated
what I will present the next alright so
as I say that we can extend with
composition and so on but let's look at
something that doesn't use composition
so let's look at report noisy max for
the one that are not familiar so here we
want we let's say we have some item and
we have some scoring function for each
item and we want to report the one that
maximizes the disk or okay one way to do
this is for instance by computing in
Instagram add in Laplace and then take
the element that is the maximal score
now
I learn not to click at least one for
each presentation I'm allowed to do that
so now if we just do a naive analysis of
these algorithms we do any analysis with
composition we can show that these
k-epsilon differentially private but
this is not the interest the interest of
this algorithm what we want to do is
instead probably prove this algorithm
salon differentially private and how can
why this is Epsilon differentially
private the idea is that mainly we look
at two databases we look at a bunch of
query we add noise to each one of them
and then I assume that they are one
sensitive and then we are looking at
something like this where the green part
I come from database D Prime and the
blue part from database D and it is true
that if we look at realization maybe we
can have that one the max that is Maxum
one will not happen in the other but if
we look over all and we try to
coordinate the noise we can show that
mainly we are allowed to pay just for
the max result now this is a very high
level intuition maybe other people at
different intuition but let's try to
prove it formally
okay now I will not prove exactly report
a noisy max but I will prove what is
called the report one-sided noisy max so
this is lightly difference the main
difference is that instead of using
Laplace here we use the positive a
Laplace okay so one sided Laplace wide
yeah or an exponential distribution
now why do we do this first because
composition doesn't apply at all because
one Laplace is even not differentially
private so we cannot apply composition
second is that this gives an
implementation of the exponential
mechanism so at the end of the day what
we will have proved is that in an
implementation of the exponential
mechanism then through this report
Nassim axis difference
now let me try to go quickly through the
corner so this function takes K queries
takes the daytime than Epsilon I return
one index in particular what it does it
goes through the goes through the
queries it had the two each query these
exponential noise or this one-sided
Laplace and then try to just find a
maximal one and keep that a maximal one
and then return the maximum okay we use
a bit of variables in particular we use
the current result and we check the
current result against the best result
we saw so far and if this is the case we
say that the index all of the query we
are looking at is the max and we update
the best to the current now there is
only one thing that is a bit stranger
this equal to one that we use for the
first step
I was I guess I was wondering if it
changes anything or makes it easier or
harder if you just sort of consider it
two separate things one where you you
know add noise to all the scores and
then then we go from you know you're
sort of doing to two things in one while
live yeah yeah you know if undergraduate
students or anything to go by makes the
program harder to reason about that's
true so I think that concretely nothing
change you need to use the same kind of
reasoning but you is the modularization
of how you structured approach the
change a bit there is a lot of work that
we can do in that direction now what
strategy shall we use so here I want we
we use something that people use a lot
on pen and paper but for us we need to
make it explicit and is this definition
of point-wise differential privacy or
this a reformulation of point-wise
differential privacy if you so I assume
that the that the output domain is
discrete then what we can do is to look
at the indistinguishability on one
particular element of the output domain
and then check that the deltas a map in
our case we don't use that in this
setting I don't use Delta we just use
epsilon but we can deal also with Delta
but the key point is that we can focus
on one s at the time now why this is
interesting because if we turn this into
a rule and we remember that what the
strategy we use to prove is symbolic so
we don't go brute force what we can do
is that we can generalize over s and so
s becomes just one possible output is
that what you do on paper you don't
really take as one is two
free but you take an arbitrary yes is
the way natural proof on pen and paper
go but now we can internalize these also
in our proof so we can say that if for
every s we are able to show that we pay
something and we have this post
condition that say if the first output
is equal to s then also the second
output is equal to s then we can prove
the overall program differentially
private now there is a this post
condition is a detail I'm happy to
explain why it has exactly the shape if
you want later but the key point here
also bond focus on the Delta the key
point here for us is a really the
generalization so that we can say we
look at 1s in general which in
yes which in our setting allow us really
to just focus on a particular s so we
have this variable s and now that we can
use and that this will be were specific
[Music]
okay I'm not sure where I got
what can you explain the first post
condition so it says if under both
inputs you would get output s and you
paid epsilon and Delta s which is
specific to s and if I this exposes like
something I was confused about what it
means the statement paid epsilon Delta
like what that actually means in
particular what does that mean in
conjunction with like a get I will come
back later that's exactly the coupling
near there is a why we call this
coupling so we pay to get different
couplings that's the idea but I will
come back if you let me go through the
verification I will come back to this ok
I see it so let me go back yeah speaking
of semantics so here we are we are
saying sorry this should have been sent
yeah so if I'm a adjacent and I Ribeira
this means that I cannot distinguish
anymore at the two output because they
are equal but two arrived there I yet to
pay epsilon and Delta that's why I try
to put the path sent it means that so in
your privacy budget in the usual way you
have to consume epsilon and Delta do
we're asking like what are the semantics
of the statement hey that's one dollar
so is it a statement of the form
you know I've got these two I'm tracking
two distributions and it's a it's like a
coupling statement that says there
exists a coupling of these two
probability distributions under which
they are equal with probability one and
let me go to the definition so that we
have the exact semantics so for them and
then I will go back if needed so what we
call approximate coupling is still so
coupling usually is used to put two
distribution on the same space and they
are we do to the modification one is we
have an explicit relation between that
make the coupling explicit and the other
is we do this approximation but let me
go today which is a usually divergence
but let me go
[Music]
this is the definition and unfortunately
is a bit longer but let me try to read
you so now we have two distribution mu1
mu2 and we say that we have an
approximate coupling where the
approximate is for epsilon delta and for
the formula as the is a relation so mu1
mu2 are two distribution and we have a
coupling in our sense if we can see two
probability distribution on the joint
space and d are we are a bit different
from the usual coupling because usually
you want one probability distribution on
the joint space here we take two of them
and the reason is because we also end on
some distribution and so this to did
these two are sometimes needed so and we
want that the left margin of mu L is a
mu one at the right margin of mu R is mu
2 this is similar to standard coupling
and now one of the key point is that the
support of this coupling is in this
relation s
okay
and then we require mainly that they
that these two are epsilon
indistinguishable this to distribution
epsilon Delta indistinguishable this is
the precise semantics now the way I was
using pain is to say that to get desired
I see this in this way to get this
relation s you are paying in the sense
that you are making them
indistinguishable with respect to this
our nation s epsilon and Delta
let me give you an example that is
different so we already saw an example
let me go back
so this is one I was saying that if we
start with two input that are adjacent
and we are the Laplace of 1 over epsilon
then we can show the equivalence
relation by paying epsilon so it means
you look at the same value and they are
epsilon indistinguishable so that's
saying that you L and you are like
output 1 equals of the two is the
description of s yes exactly so mu1 mu2
mainly are in the diagonal so mu and mu
are are in the diagonal the diagonal is
where they are equal but this is not the
only way let me show you another example
which is a similar
one second let me just mention this so
now you are not looking at the diagonal
anymore but you look at output 1 plus K
and that equal to output 2 and what you
pay and is the same program here I was
doing this for the exponential but we
have a similar hole for Laplace now you
pay K times epsilon this is what you
call a sliding property for instance in
your a smooth sensitivity paper
I'm still parsing sorry so input 1 minus
input 2 somewhere between minus K and K
prime minus K and then yeah this is
because we are looking at the sari and
the one side that the so is a bit more
Isaac I think ok but if you think it
this is still like it I mean this is
almost like that statement about the
diagonal right this is like you know you
are using a different relation but it's
still one where like the two random
variables are just like a one on one
correspondence this is exactly the
sliding property of laplace generalize
to only the points more interesting one
is that one you showed us that you were
gonna use for report noisy max that I
think one for this before stop no
earlier you had the one without put 1
equals s enough but you so for instance
this is another so if we take we use it
a lot in the proof so if you take again
you are the Laplace one side that
Laplace now what you can do is that to
just use a coupling which is a zero
indistinguishable by requiring that they
output preserve the distance over the
input
I mean same distribution same yeah which
is relaxing and adding the noise doesn't
make things worse yeah exactly
these rules do you know so so I will
probably not show completely the example
because I'm running out of time but I
think is better to just discuss so these
are all can be proved inside the system
but not inside the logic and let me be
more specific
usually this kind of logic are built in
some system that allow us to reason
about their soundness as well and then
you can use these rules as macro to do
the proof like I was doing so they are
proof correct but inside the bigger
system so just that I will not go
through this but just the key point of
report on Isaac Mac so let me go here is
that is that we need to proceed by cases
so what we do is and mainly to think
about in this way now we are reasoning
about s so we can think about the loops
before s we can think about the cases
and then the loop after s since the
output must be as we know that we don't
want to pay for the loop before and for
the loop after so for the we use this
coupling that we just saw the one that
pays zero in all the iteration before as
and all the iteration after s and then
we use another coupling for the case
where we are in s
which is this one and these make sure
that so we'll use these with k equal
that one but mainly to make sure that we
can prove this post condition result so
that if we take the branch if we go
through the leaf for the first run we
can force also the second run to go into
Dave and then we keep a pain zero until
the end
this is a at eye level the proof
and the detail in our in my slides let
me conclude by saying we have other
coupling dis approximate coupling for
other divergences and remy divergence
and that CDP and so on is not a totally
trivial to do this for from the formal
perspective and there are also 4f
divergence more in general this method
can be automated and just in to work on
these with house and house will be
around so during the first workshops I
will give more detail about their way of
automating this approach and they I
think is very interesting another work I
wanted to mention is that a very similar
kind of verification can also be done
for reasoning about probability of
failure and this allow us to reason
about accuracy for instance for report
noisy max we can with a similar proof we
can prove its accuracy as you would do
pen what this logic internalizes the
Union bound now I take a few more
minutes with the Sun pointer that I
think I would like I think they would be
interesting for some of the possible
interaction in this semester so I think
they first Adam already mention it and I
think is an interesting question try to
find a common way to try to build some
software infrastructure that support a
different effort for differential
privacy but I will go first on this
because Adam I already mentioned this
several time the other one is I think it
would be really great to add basic
mechanism like let's say Laplace or
exponential mechanisms that are fully
verified and
and in the sense of having some basic
component may be written in a low-level
language like C but which is something
we are sure that is correct maybe
correct also against the some of the
low-level attacker and I personally plan
to work on this but I would like to hear
more from other people about this and
whether this is something interesting
another topic that I think we should be
discussed at this semester is a finding
hunter example to differential privacy
implementation so since differential
privacy has been deployed by many
different people that sometime they
don't have the expertise that there is
in this room and many of them are
worried that their implementation are
not private so I think having some way
of thinking about finding violation is a
good way to help and the deployment of
differential privacy sorry I did the
ballot list and another thing that I
already discuss with several of you is
we use a lot disk coupling base argument
and we also use a lot of divergences in
our verification and the recently
several work have shown lower bounds
based on a some kind of argument based
on coupling and the idea is usually in
the proof that I saw taking some
divergence maybe depending on the
problem that you formulate the problem
in terms of some divergence and try to
show that by some transformation you
have a bound on the divergence you need
for actual privacy last one
I think formal methods doesn't need to
be fought only about
something for privacy in this semester
but there are also other direction that
it can be useful for for instance John
and I are working on some program
analysis technique for more adaptive
data analysis and houses work a lot on
fairness and formal methods so I think
it would be very interesting for me and
therefore other formal methods people
learn more about other possible oh right
this is my question was about how and
end can we like just just what are the
ends of verifying a basic mechanism at
hand do you mean like on particular
hardware so in some model of what C is
yeah so that's a good question so
different so I think what I was
referring to with some of the world that
are going on in more the cryptographic
world where they are trying to verify
some crypto primitive end to end and
usually the way at least some of the
work I have in mind the way they do this
is they prove some property of the 11
language which is then translated to C
and then we use some infrastructure that
is already built to reason about C
programs and these can go to assembly so
we can go to some architecture or to
some intermediate architecture like an
al BM or things of this kind so I think
the lowest we push the argument and the
better it is now the the effort I think
which is me that is really reason a bit
of two things one is differential
privacy on finite did something but is
not the final word people at Harbor the
victor vulture was working on this
here's some result I think there is the
need of thinking more about differential
privacy in the finite space
finite memory and and then like maybe
there is a more formal method effort in
trying to understand how to push down
there is a lot of software a lot of
verification effort that has already
been done like C to give you an example
C has already been formalized
different memory model different
architecture so there is a lot of
working
you think Marco for all three yeah
[Music]
[Applause]